Transcriptor: TED Translators admin
Revisor: Emma Gon
Amigas y amigos:
Estoy aquí porque los organizadores
de este evento querían
que fuera inaugurado
por la persona más nerd de Costa Rica.
(Risas y aplausos)
Pero Franklin Chang solo podía
hablar hoy a las once y media.
(Risas)
Entonces me pidieron a mí
que igual reunía algunas
de las condiciones requeridas.
Mi buen amigo
Roberto Sasso me garantizó
que el auditorio también iba a estar
lleno de nerds como él y como yo.
Pero hay aquí gente demasiado bonita.
Una de dos: o Roberto se equivocó,
o vamos mejorando como especie social.
(Risas)
Si es así como los nerds se ven ahora,
creo que soy el eslabón perdido
de su cadena evolutiva.
(Risas)
Veo que soy unos meses
mayor que ustedes.
Unos 400 o 500 meses.
(Risas)
Pero no importa.
Uno tiene la edad que tienen sus ideas.
Cuando se trata de perseguir ilusiones
puedo ser el hermano gemelo
de la persona más joven
que hoy nos acompaña.
Desde esa juventud del pensamiento,
donde brota la fuerza del cambio,
quiero dirigirles un mensaje esta mañana.
He venido a hablar de América Latina.
He venido a hablar de
la prima loca de la familia humana.
He venido a hablar de esa región,
que como alguien dijo alguna vez,
haría de Kafka un costumbrista.
No hay en el mundo
una franja de tierra
más llena de prodigios
y de contradicciones.
No hay en el mundo una esquina,
en donde convivan con tanto desorden,
escritores universales
y campesinos analfabetas,
políticos estadistas
y dictadores militares,
charlatanes ricos
e intelectuales pobres,
almas puritanas y
fiesteros irredimibles.
Nacimos en el centro
de una copa que decanta
los mejores y los peores
néctares de nuestra especie.
Eso nos hace propensos al absurdo,
pero también nos hace
sensibles al milagro.
Porque América Latina
es infinitamente diversa,
sus posibilidades son también infinitas.
Imaginen por un instante,
lo que sería nuestra región,
si le otorgáramos más poder
a los programadores, diseñadores
en lugar de a
los coroneles y los generales.
Si destináramos nuestros recursos
a comprar más libros y computadoras,
en lugar de más misiles
y tanques de guerra.
Si en lugar de muros
y cercas alambradas,
nuestras fronteras compartieran
cables de alta tensión
o redes de fibra óptica.
Si en lugar de repetir en las escuelas
la historia eterna de campañas bélicas,
nuestros jóvenes tuvieran la oportunidad
de asistir a charlas como esta.
Imaginen a esa América Latina.
Ansíenla, quiéranla y súbanse
las mangas de la camisa,
porque nos toca a todos
nosotros construirla.
Creo que todos aquí
perseguimos una misma utopía.
La de una región
en donde el desarrollo alcance
a la mayor cantidad de personas.
En donde todos los jóvenes concluyan,
al menos, la educación secundaria.
En donde cada habitante
tenga acceso a Internet
y a un teléfono celular.
En donde exista trabajo suficiente
y un sistema universal
de atención a la salud.
En donde el crimen
no nos robe la esperanza.
En donde la pobreza
no avergüence a nuestros pueblos.
En donde la degradación ambiental
no amenace con borrar
los trazos de la existencia humana.
Nos falta mucho para llegar a esa utopía.
El 42% de los homicidios
con armas de fuego
que cada año ocurren en el mundo
tienen lugar en América Latina,
donde vive menos del 10%
de la población mundial.
Uno de cada tres jóvenes latinoamericanos,
no llega nunca a ver un aula de secundaria
y solo uno de cada diez logra
matricularse en la universidad.
Como consecuencia la escolaridad
promedio en la región
ronda apenas los 8 años.
Una tercera parte
de la población latinoamericana
vive actualmente en la pobreza.
Las mujeres y los niños llevan
la peor parte de este flagelo,
que tiene su raíz en la tremenda
incapacidad de nuestros gobiernos
para cosechar los frutos de la democracia
y elevar las condiciones
de vida de nuestro pueblo.
Alrededor del 66% de la pérdida
de cubierta forestal en el mundo
en lo que va del siglo XXI,
ha tenido lugar aquí en América Latina.
Que ha sido también víctima
de las terribles consecuencias
del cambio climático.
Somos la región más desigual del planeta.
Miles de personas mueren
cada año en nuestras naciones
por enfermedades prevenibles.
Solo una fracción de
nuestros habitantes sabe usar Internet.
Nuestras democracias son débiles.
Nuestra innovación es raquítica.
Pero aunque nuestro pasado sea
un acervo de oportunidades perdidas,
no somos una región fracasada.
Si algo tiene América Latina,
es potencial.
Realizar ese potencial requiere dinero.
Yo he venido aquí a decirles
de dónde lo podemos sacar.
Hay una cuenta de ahorros
en el banco del tiempo.
Un monto que hasta ahora
no hemos querido tocar:
el gasto militar.
El año pasado los países
de la región destinaron
alrededor de 60 000 millones
de dólares a sus ejércitos.
Ese es el costo de la guerra.
¿Pero qué pasaría si gastáramos
esos recursos de otra manera?
¿Qué pasaría si convirtiéramos
los costos de la guerra
en dividendos de la paz?
Si los países latinoamericanos
redujeran a la mitad su gasto militar,
podrían aumentar la inversión
en investigación y desarrollo
en 1% de su Producto Interno Bruto.
En el caso de ciertos países
como El Salvador o Ecuador,
esa cifra podría ser mucho mayor.
Pero tal vez la mitad del gasto militar
nos parece demasiado.
Bueno, si los países latinoamericanos
redujeran en una cuarta parte
su gasto en armas y soldados,
tendrían recursos suficientes
para comprar 150 millones
de computadoras
del programa "One Laptop per Child".
Con esto, podría entregarse
una computadora a cada niño
que se encuentra actualmente
en el sistema educativo.
Pero tal vez una cuarta parte
nos parezca exagerado.
Bueno, si los países latinoamericanos
redujeran en un 10%,
su gasto en armas y soldados,
alcanzaría para instalar wifi gratuito
en las ciudades principales
de nuestra región,
potenciando las oportunidades
de nuestros pueblos
que habitan mayoritariamente
en las zonas urbanas.
Y si les parece mucho
una décima parte,
les digo que
si los países latinoamericanos
redujeran su gasto militar
tan solo en un 5%
sería suficiente para poder
otorgar una beca estudiantil
como las del programa Avancemos
que introdujo mi gobierno,
a 3 millones de jóvenes,
durante un año.
Si dejaran de comprar
un solo helicóptero artillado,
darían alimento escolar a
miles de niños durante la primaria.
Si dejaran de comprar
un solo avión de combate,
podrían proteger decenas
de kilómetros cuadrados de bosque.
Y si dejaran de pagar el salario
de uno solo de sus soldados,
podrían pagar el salario de
al menos un profesor de inglés.
Estos son los dividendos de la paz.
Esto es lo que América Latina
ganaría si dejara de apostar
en la ruleta rusa del gasto militar.
Yo llevo 25 años de
estar hablando sin descanso
sobre este tema.
25 años de estar hablando ante oídos
que no quieren escuchar.
Me dirán que no tiene
sentido seguir luchando.
Pero yo les aseguro
que las condiciones han cambiado.
Porque hace 25 años
no existía la posibilidad de
que un ciudadano común
iniciara un "blog" un día cualquiera
y ese "blog" fuera más leído
que un periódico o una buena revista.
No existía la posibilidad de crear
un grupo de "facebook" y convocar
en cuestión de semanas,
a 3 millones de personas
a manifestarse en torno a una propuesta.
No existía la posibilidad
de convertir un video casero
en un fenómeno de sensación mundial
Este es el mundo
que hizo famosa a Susan Boyd.
Sí. A Susan Boyd.
Con el poder de un clic.
Este es el mundo en el que Wikipedia
prácticamente ha desplazado
a las enciclopedias,
que durante siglos dictaron
la palabra oficial del pensamiento.
Este es el mundo en
el que cualquier persona
puede seguir gratuitamente
los cursos de física o de cálculo del MIT,
la más prestigiosa universidad
tecnológica del planeta
sin moverse de la sala de su casa.
Nunca antes las personas normales
los que no son presidentes,
ni generales, ni gerentes, ni directores,
habían tenido tanto poder.
Por eso creo que tenemos esperanza.
Porque tenemos voz y
porque tenemos músculo,
porque tenemos la capacidad de presionar
por acciones concretas e inmediatas.
Un celular, un iPod, una computadora,
son herramientas poderosas de cambio.
Parafraseando a Khalil Gibran,
hoy les pido que no usemos
esas herramientas para matar
el tiempo, usémoslas para vivirlo.
Para hacer la diferencia.
Para construir aunque sea
una astilla del mundo
que siempre todos nosotros hemos soñado.
Porque si la tecnología ha hecho
poderosa a la gente normal,
también debe hacerla responsable.
Desde que ustedes tienen la capacidad
de pronunciarse en contra
de las vejaciones y las injusticias,
tienen también el deber de hacerlo.
Tienen también el deber de contribuir
con el progreso ético de la humanidad.
Este milenio dio inicio con
el más devastador ataque terrorista,
seguido por una guerra
declarada unilateralmente
y una crisis económica
nacida de la codicia.
Es obvio que un mundo
más interconectado,
no necesariamente es un mundo
más justo o más humano.
Los valores no vienen
en el disco duro de una laptop.
No vienen en formato mp3,
ni en una nueva aplicación de twitter.
Para eso no existe nada más
que el corazón humano,
no existe más que la bondad,
no existe más que el coraje.
La segunda década de este siglo,
merece más de lo que hasta ahora
hemos podido construir
y más de lo que hasta ahora
hemos sido capaces de evitar.
Nos corresponde la tarea
de brindarle a nuestra región
y a nuestro planeta,
una nueva oportunidad.
La historia humana, amigas y amigos,
se escribe en borrador.
Por eso es una historia plagada
de tachones, frases sin sentido,
palabras repetidas
y párrafos sin terminar.
No sé cuántas veces en el curso de
la historia, alguien ha escrito la frase:
"Y viviremos para siempre en paz".
Pero aunque esa frase ha sido borrada
incontables veces del cuaderno humano,
aunque no tengamos todavía
un capítulo sin guerra y sin locura,
en los siglos y siglos en que hemos
habitado este pedazo del universo,
nada impide que seamos
cuerdos el día de mañana.
Nada impide
que aprendamos por fin
a escribir en limpio
las palabras de la paz.
De hecho, la realidad ha cambiado.
Este evento es un prueba de ello.
Si los nerds del mundo
pueden hacerse guapos,
si un presidente puede aprender
a la edad de los 60 años
a usar YouTube y googlear,
si un grupo de jóvenes
puede reunirse a reflexionar
sobre las ideas
que vale la pena difundir,
entonces sí estamos
mejor que al principio.
Entonces sí tenemos razón para creer
que seremos capaces de
construir un mundo maravilloso,
donde las armas no reciban los recursos
que merecen los seres humanos;
donde la inteligencia sirva para promover
el desarrollo sostenible de los pueblos;
donde la tecnología brinde
cada vez más poder a la gente
y en donde la gente comprenda la inmensa
responsabilidad que esto conlleva.
No debemos olvidar nunca
las hermosas palabras
de Margaret Mead cuando dijo:
"Nunca duden de que un pequeño
grupo de ciudadanos
pensantes, comprometidos,
puede cambiar el mundo.
De hecho es lo único
que ha logrado hacerlo".
En manos de ustedes descansa
la potestad de construir la utopía.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)